- So Donald Trump has been
impeached for the second time.
The only president in history
to ever be impeached twice
and it happened in just over a year
since the last time that he was impeached,
though of course he was
acquitted in the Senate.
So what does that mean?
Well, obviously now that
the House has impeached,
which is effectively the indictment,
now that will be referred to the Senate,
and the Senate will try the case.
Now, unfortunately,
the Senate is in recess
and it's currently being run
by Senate majority
leader, Mitch McConnell,
and that's not going to change,
because Chuck Schumer can't become
the Senate majority leader
until the democratic senators
from Georgia are seated,
Kamala Harris' replacement
in California is seated,
and Kamala Harris takes her
place as the Vice President
to break the 50/50 tie in the Senate.
So that's where we are.
Stay tuned for more
impeachment related legal news
and as always, I'll see you in court.